let's go to bite from Deltona bite
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey thanks David
um I just want to start by saying that
um I am sort of a fellow bicultural uh
Denizen of the world I I was uh have
split time
um from the time I was zero to 18
between Peru and the United States and
uh the reason I mention that I think
it's important because when you do get
your education outside of the United
States of course you kind of you know
pull yourself out of the indoctrination
stream
um you know the cultural
um you know indoctrination and social
conditioning that takes place if you
experience the American educational
system from you know you know
kindergarten through high school
um so I just kind of want to throw that
out I wanted to get your take on an idea
that I had based on a letter that I
received from Marco Rubio with regards
to abortion okay
um the thing that he States in his
letter is uh that he is defending the
rights of the 65 million unborn children
that did not get to experience the dream
the American dream because of the during
the 50 years right they were never born
in other words right right so he's
defending their rights now I had a
thought about possibly painting them
into a corner uh because technically
speaking you know from their position my
understanding would be that they are
they are defending the rights of the
fetus to be born yeah and here's the
thing I think it's important to mention
they would say that it's a person
already and that's why it has rights
right so exactly but here's where I'm
going with this yes now when we're born
of course we have a federal social
security number which basically
establishes IR uh our identity I
personally think that we should be able
to legally argue in court that if the
states are going to defend the fetus
they would be required to give that
fetus and identification number and at
that point in time also of course uh
State all the benefits that that fetus
is going to be uh uh and the host is
going to receive on the basis of that uh
uh establishment of identity got it yes
I'm one step ahead of you on this I've
got a number of different clips you can
find in which I point out this hypocrisy
if you're talking about a person at
conception uh should have a Social
Security number should qualify for child
support
should prevent a mother if if the
pregnant mother is an undocumented
immigrant she shouldn't be able to be
deported because it's already a person
and it's here in the United States
there's a whole list of these your uh
the concept is absolutely right and I've
elaborated on it before
okay so you said that do you agree with
that that would that would paint them
into a corner no I mean they'll come up
with they'll come up with some way out
of it but I agree with you that it
exposes a hypocrisy for sure
okay all right cool well thanks for uh
your comment on that and sorry I missed
that before but started started
listening to you you know right uh
around uh the the 2016 election or right
before that I appreciate it very much
thank you for the call
all right take it easy all right you too
uh yeah that's that's very very uh
astute observation for sure there